[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight a big news day maybe a pivotal
one the DOJ released its long-awaited
internal review was written by the
department's inspector general and it's
packed with information in a few minutes
Donald Trump jr. will join us to respond
to it but first what is in the report
well the document is more than 500 pages
long and parts of it are complex and yet
within minutes of its release the
hairspray geniuses of cable news had it
neatly summarized for the rest of us it
was a tough day for the FBI they said
but here's the bottom line
a month-long investigation found no
evidence that political bias played any
role in this high-profile criminal
investigation
that's almost verbatim what they said on
the other channels we watched and they
repeated it nearly word-for-word at the
top of every hour all day long almost
like a talking point which of course is
what it was keep this in mind if you're
looking to understand what's actually
happening in this country always assume
the opposite of whatever they're telling
you on the big news stations and that's
certainly the case here they are lying
in fact today's IG report is a virtual
catalog of political bias and abuse of
power it is true that investigators
found no evidence at all that Jim Comey
was trying to sabotage Hillary Clinton's
presidential campaign no surprise there
coming as a partisan Democrat as he has
explained repeatedly on his book tour
the bias and there was a lot of it was
against Donald Trump and his campaign
and there's an enormous amount of that
on display in this report Trump is a
loathsome human FBI lawyer Lisa page
wrote to her boyfriend FBI official
Peter Strock he is an idiot awful an
enormous douche a disaster he simply
cannot be President he's not ever going
to become president right right she
wrote to struck at one point no strike
replied no he won't we'll stop it keep
in mind these are the people running the
investigations into Donald Trump and
Hillary Clinton in the middle of a
presidential race it's almost
unbelievable but you know what's even
more unbelievable Peter struck still
works at the FBI the man who promised to
stop a presidential candidate from
getting elected
is still flexing a salary at our most
powerful law-enforcement agency if
you're looking for evidence a political
bias there you have it and if you don't
believe it imagine this headline for
example say ten years ago Barack Obama
simply cannot become president we will
stop him wrote FBI agent Peter Strahm
who still works at the bureau can you
imagine no he'd be fired immediately
First Amendment be damned
and by the way Strachan page were not
alone they're not even the standout
cases in this report the document quotes
another FBI attorney wondering quote
what I could have done differently to
stop Donald Trump's election as
president that same official later
describes himself as part of the anti
Trump resistance for some reason the DOJ
is hiding that lawyer's name from the
public we do know he served on the
Muller team until February of this year
of course he did and there's a lot more
in the report hundreds of pages of it it
turns out Jim Comey used a personal
email account to conduct a government
business just like the woman he was in
the process of investigating for doing
the same thing
irony alert Hillary's secret server by
the way it did indeed have classified
information on it and some of that
information was obtained by a foreign
intelligence service at least one
remember we suggested that very thing
and they scoffed derisive Lee well it
turns out it's true like so much the
report goes on to reveal that FBI agents
routinely took bribes from journalists
in return for leaking information people
have gone to jail for things like that
in Washington but of course no one at
FBI was seriously penalized for it it
goes on like this the FBI is out of
control the current director Chris ray
acknowledged as much today at a press
conference luckily ray has a solution
going forward he said FBI employees will
receive professional anti bias training
now that men might not make the Criminal
Investigations less corrupt but it will
definitely bring a heightened sense of
sensitivity to questions of transgender
bathrooms and toxic masculinity so that
might make you feel better
fox chief intelligence correspondent
catherine herridge has been on this from
the very beginning and joins us now with
the report what would you say is the
some of the impression you get of
director Comey from this report
Catherine
well this is the report right here
Tucker and it's as you mentioned over
500 pages long and the bottom line with
director Comey is that the Inspector
General found that he was insubordinate
when he made that July 2016 public
statement about the Clinton email case
where director Comey recommended against
criminal charges for the mishandling of
information and the Inspector General
said that Comey deliberately hid what he
was going to say from his boss the
Attorney General Loretta Lynch and her
deputy Sally Yates and there was no
other way to describe it but it amounted
to insubordination and I think that's
important because for Kemp call me
rather it's part of his legacy right
he's done a book about loyalty he's
touring the country talking about
leadership and this really is sort of a
footnote or a bookend on his legacy
Tucker one of the headlines of this
report which we just quoted at some
length was the text message from Peter
stalked ELISA page and we promised rain
stopped him mr. Strock still works at
the FBI has there been any indication of
whether there'll be consequences for him
right so what we learned today from the
FBI director is that they're going to
refer some of the employees for
administrative action and I just want to
kind of decode that for you a bit
administrative action it's not criminal
prosecution and for many of these people
who are you know implicated in the
report they've already left the bureau
they've retired out right they've just
left on their own or they've been you
know reassigned struck is still there
and based on what we read in the report
today there seems to be evidence as you
mentioned of this political bias and if
I could just say one thing I think it's
so important to pay attention to the
language in the report what they say is
that they didn't find testimonial or
documentary evidence so no paperwork and
no witness testimony that political bias
infected the decisions of the Clinton
email campaign
investigation pardon me that doesn't
mean it didn't happen or it wasn't there
but they're saying they didn't find
evidence of it
right so I think that that's an
important distinction it is it certainly
is and thanks for pointing out Catherine
Harridge appreciate it